game we got a live show bombshell to
drop on you right now just added a
second show at the Vogel theater August
11th over there in Red Bank New Jersey
grab some ticks and come see the boys
yeah shout out to the Army garbage we
sold it out in four days so we added a
second show get those tickets before
they're gone because they're gonna go we
love yous also May 24th will be in
Louisville Kentucky there you go uh then
June 14th 15th we're going to be in
Cleveland Ohio and Columbus Ohio then
again back to Red Bank New Jersey get
those tickets we love you be adding
dates welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit there with your
favorite comedians and we find it at the
girl to be classy yeah just a big old
piece of trash I'm your host Dave Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
out back here with Toadies in the new
edition baby she's out doing a little
fishing uh-oh over there at the VFW okay
trolling looking for some night crawlers
if you know what I'm talking about my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me he is the CEO of Ru garbage he is
an international businessman and he's my
best pal in the whole wide world give it
up for KJ Kevin James Ryan everybody
what up gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure your rate if you
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
cooking then obviously I'd be remiss if
I didn't mention the greatest website of
all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage you
check it out it's a party over there
gang yeah it's a good time having a nice
quick shout out to our producer X Jordan
Air the magic man makes us all look good
works to ones the twos the threes and
the fours he crosses the t's and he dots
the eyes and now you can get a little
sneak peek at him on that Toby cam give
it up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby
McMullen everybody what up dude we got
Uncle barbecue in the Edition bro talk
about a guy who knows his way around to
Portillo's Hot Dog
[__] real one in the building Baby
Let's Go Gang the long hair ain't lying
we could not be more excited to have our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest back with us again today it's been
a minute we are so excited he's on tour
right now absolutely fantastic stand-up
comedian has a brand new special out
right now shocks and struts do yourself
a favor check it out and give it up for
Mr Kyle knee what's up buddy hi boys
let's [__] sharp man I like the chain
I like the jacket this is me trying to
change Pace
really it was a big event that I went
with a jewelry okay that is a big step
but it looks great I would have never
pegged it as a new look it seems normal
to you it's like to be middle age and
start doing accessories
I got shiny watch there you go this
guy's a full boy you got a bank account
too yeah I got a couple bucks let's see
that watch what are you rocking with
it's a Seiko oh that's nice though it's
not like it looks shiny but it's not you
know it's what it's all about this thing
hasn't worked in four years no it's like
a top level Camry you know
fully loaded yeah yeah
yeah
the moon roof and the spoiler yeah I'm
not gonna I'm not a [__] with an
Avalon
buddy congrats on the new special man I
just peaked those numbers that thing is
cooking what's going on it's getting
around you know yeah that's pretty
shabby what is the uh we're gonna do
just do a little retouch on you because
it's been a minute
um what's the van situation the Vans
Advanced situation is the van uh I've
been living in a van I was no I wasn't
living in the van I got a PO Box I'm
doing better than that
access to indoor plumbing okay
okay no I hit well because I bought at
the beginning of pandemic because like I
didn't know like you know everybody like
what's gonna happen remember that those
feet like
we might have wonky time there might not
be airplanes anymore
I might have to just go you know just
drive town to town and set up and pedal
my Wares like like at all right up folks
yeah like a knife sharpener he's going
down you're doing demos out in the
parking lots ice cream truck speaker on
the top where are you from Miss what do
you do you guys ever get hemorrhoids
that's a crazy thing huh
so yeah but now I just take it out it's
like more of an RV I get out there and I
still uh no is it nice is it done nice a
guy built it okay and it was the one van
he built okay you can tell
and he did it he did a good job for
himself and then it's a prototype yeah
he built it to his specifications as a
single man and then he met a woman and
she's like I'm not gonna live in a van
with you and then he sold it to me and
my girlfriend's like I'm not gonna hang
out in this van with you but uh pick it
up on a trend here chicks don't like
beans I do well I I got my appendix out
and I did get to keep that little jar of
peeing so that's coming handy in the van
there you go oh they Tangled sure yeah
how was the appendix did it started it's
hard bothering you it started hurting
you or did you catch it before that oh
that was weird I had no symptoms I was
just all of a sudden like oh I feel like
you know like the different like oh the
inside Pains of like sure elbow oh I hit
my elbow my elbow hurts but inside here
you're like all right man weed and
Sprite and see if that fix it
dude THC and seven up but see uh that
doesn't do it [__] we're gonna have to
get into the deductibles get the Sierra
Mist over here I don't know what to tell
you
um you flew here though I would assume
right yeah yeah I'm part of the modern
world
I have uh they didn't take the Oregon
Trail
I thumbed my way across the country
um so where are you based out of now
where are you posted up I'm in Oregon or
again said you were out there in a bird
nice bird Suburban just outside uh just
outside of Portland Oregon and your feet
you said you were feeling it out there a
little bit
it's like it's like the first uh
it's a town called Beaverton it's
basically the Brooklyn of Portland
um no it's fine I'm like a third of a
mile away from the Nike campus oh I know
where that is I went out there okay yeah
and it's real fun to see those dudes
that work at Nike but aren't athletes
like they're just in accounting but they
are the freshest Nike gear yeah they
look like Tiger Woods out there yeah but
there's any there's an Indian buffet
right across the street and they see
lunch break see these guys just can't
wait to just light up a smoke and just
in like the nicest track suits I can't
wait to pound five pounds of tikka
masala right now just do it baby oh my
God I dig you guys what uh what uh what
grocery store are you going to out there
what grocery store yeah what are you
hitting up okay all right here's my
options right we just got out there
right they got uh they got it's not
what's called uh [__] What's this called
it's not it's not Whole Foods it's like
a fancy one oh not Trader Joe's that's
not Trader Joe's is it the one they have
in L.A oh God damn why can't I remember
the name of this place that's right
there it's Wegmans no but it's nice and
it's too it's super expensive and you
went we went through the first couple
times like we just moved here sure let's
cook at home yeah and then uh right next
to it is a employee-owned place called
WinCo that's also open 24 hours which is
my favorite thing about a grocery my
kind of speed right there and you're
just like you can't you it's like cash
or debit like they don't even take
credit cards I'm like holy [__] this is
my spot yeah like okay I I I dipped into
the fancy stuff and now I'm over at
WinCo and uh I'm down with it there's
something about a grocery store in the
middle of the night when it's just nice
and clean and quiet in there and you
just strolling through the aisles the
right like when you get them when
they've faced up everything like
everything
yeah yeah I used to do that I used I
used to work at a Kmart and we would
face everything up and then that's the
like it's peaceful yeah everything you
could tell the employees are proud of it
too like yeah in six hours this is gonna
be a nightmare go check out cereal why
you still can as soon as I can be pile
is going to look like me live
so get in there now it's color
coordinating it's also at that point
when it's clean and it's empty and it's
whatever it's midnight anything's
possible you're like I can make a
lasagna right now like you're just
walking through like I can do anything
it is yeah there's no like like gopher
holes dug into the bin candy from
children just reaching in there some
nine-year-old in the bottom of it all
right man
so I'm vegetarian but I was getting cat
food cat's not vegetarian so I was
living out my fantasies we're like oh
ham and gravy I've never had gravy on a
ham before cats getting it right now and
it's so high and I'm like all right and
now I'm gonna get candy but I can't get
the lower big candy because that's when
the kids dig around yeah sure I gotta
get it and then I was just still eating
it with my hands and then I got
microwave popcorn for myself when I got
home I forgot I don't I haven't had a
microwave in three years man that's
really high you forgot what kind of
kitchen you had I got so excited about
buying home popcorn in a while I got so
excited about putting in a toaster oven
yeah
um New Seasons new season is the name of
the fans fancy one okay Seasons new
season that sounds nice it sounds like a
good rehab facility down here a new
seasons anything that's possible drying
out at new six weeks your parents come
out at the end of it insurance covers it
Ah that's all right are you cooking a
lot at the house am I cooking a lot
no but one of my trips to Winco I found
this weird little Nick chores like hot
dogs and cans and stuff like one veggie
but like there was like this hidden
three can wide section of vegetarian
meat substitutes okay that I wasn't even
looking for and I caught it out of the
corner of my eye okay I think they put
it in the ethnic food aisle because like
we don't know we don't know where this
should land but yeah where it doesn't
need its own aisle we don't know where a
can of hot dogs should be
and uh the girls not quite Indian not
quite Spanish we're not really sure yeah
just sausages and water okay we'll give
it a shot and so the girlfriend was out
of town I'm like I'm making all this
stuff this meat in the can and she
almost cut her trip short and come home
she's like this is like I'd rather see
you doing drugs just get a Bag Man
by yourself that's funny but so no
that's that's like the extent I'm like I
cooked oh I did a piece of fish the
other day I eat fish sometimes okay I
cooked a piece of fish and I was like
real proud of myself what kind of cup we
talking what kind of fish it was uh it
was a gift from my father-in-law because
he was like he's like well I don't know
what to get you because you're not like
a dude dude and uh you can get your
hamburger meat
there's a nice fish yeah okay so it's
like a like a red snapper or something
yeah yeah that's all righty toy I
watched it yeah I watched the YouTube
recipe there you go you know when they
like touch it real gently it's a real
adult right there I did that with
seasoning and cooked it and the house
smelled like fish for five days I'm like
I don't know if this is worth it
this was worth what I did
um how big is that big piece of a
property you have out there you gotta
you got a good yard
I don't know it was like it's a house
that it's like belongs to my girlfriend
and her brothers because it was like in
her family so that's how that's how we
wound up there okay and so so you're
just renting it you guys don't own it
I'm renting it she's like her and her
brothers are trying to pay it off so
they can like have it at this like like
a little rental property gotcha okay but
uh
yeah we got a nice yard well that's what
I was telling you to start we got like
fire pit and fire Pit's not dead like
it's not dug and it's just like a big
pan is it like
yeah that came with the house I mean but
it's like you buy them right yeah yeah
yeah like you can buy it like I can't
yeah I'm not just lighting a fire on the
ground which I wouldn't be you throw a
couple of rocks around there that's the
same thing that's a classier fire pit
she was just a big aluminum dish yeah he
was telling me outside he's like they
moved in right after all the fires and
[__] up there the first thing they did
was start a fire yeah and the neighbors
came over like what the [__] are you
doing yeah we're like we've been
breathing smoke for six weeks you come
over here and you're burning trash
out like we're so sorry we weren't in
town for we weren't we weren't thinking
I'm sorry
oh it's [__] awesome who's taking
care of the property you got to cut the
grass yourself or you got somebody that
does it they her brother lives in the
house they had a guy we got a guy I'm
not cutting you inherited the guy okay
I'm not cutting grass I like well I'm a
job Creator there you go you're giving
back to the economy baby let this guy
handle it he just does great undo the
misses she likes the flowers and
everything so okay he takes care of that
I'm still from a rent I'm like rental
mentality like I'm not doing [__] I pay
my rent yeah babe this is broken
you're the landlord you better call your
brothers so you stop paying rent for a
couple of weeks clogged a [__] again
get on it is there a garage at this
house oh there's a garage baby what's
going on in the garage you parking cars
in there you hanging out in there you
drinking beers in there
really I got a I bought a pull-up bar
that has been used to uh yeah
clothings and rugs that the cat throw up
on
I don't even do pull-ups anymore I
dangle off of it and I consider that
stretching there you go
I've also been that lazy yeah you just
hang out there and twirl a little bit
of the joints I got uh I got about six
bicycles okay okay two BMX bikes nice
what kind of both Brands we talking
about
I just bought I just bought one I bought
one as an adult what is it I bought a
fit fit uh subsidiary of s m bikes I
know I have I got it I had my dad send
me my s m that I bought in high school I
believe it was the s m a Philadelphia
company maybe uh I feel like it was s m
was uh SoCal okay I'm wrong uh that's
all right but that's I was I was
refurbishing that one for as a retro BMX
bike that I kind of gave up on and then
I bought the new one just because I'm
like oh it's I'm just gonna go ride a
BMX bike at the track so I go as a grown
man with no children you go to the
church
pump track and I uh that's pretty soon I
I forcefully stay away from children
because I don't want to look creepy but
now that comes off even creepy now it
looks like there's a lot like I have a
stipulation yeah we gotta watch that kid
you're just riding in a circle on the
outskirts of the park I just make sure I
got a measuring tape on me like 50 yards
kids please oh do you can you you hit
the rhythms you're pumping you're
really yeah but you can jump
you can get a little air you know what I
could do is I can have a good time
that's all that matters at the end I can
have a fun time that's all that matters
are you getting all old man padded up
you rocking elbow pads on the mountain
bikes I got all the pads mountain bikes
helmet all that [__] oh yeah dude I'm
not [__] around with that sure I'm
not I can't remember [__] as it is for
stand up I would take risk ahead injury
you could be a pro athlete with CT you
can't be a comment catch the ball throw
the ball don't talk to the Press you
know like you can do that I gotta rely
on what this thing working at at least
60 yeah at 2 A.M with 10 beers a year
yeah yeah yeah I'm already pushing it
huh okay I got a lot of remote control
cars
I'm like like ones that go fast what the
[__] yeah if you got RC cars oh yeah do
you like Tinker with her five of those
that's that's the only fun part you
crash on the break you get to fix them
you feel like a mechanic are they
gasoline he is next level trash
I put out why you boys come on into the
shop let me put on my Dickies jacket
that I'm wearing right now because I
gotta go work on some stuff stepping at
a body shop will you are they gas
powered or they electric no I got
electrical got electric so you got to
control the zipping around do you have a
track in the backyard I didn't do the
track but I got some rock crawlers so I
just drive over some old firewood out
there sometimes Drive the next door
Drive the dog next door nuts dude talk
about suspect he got BMX bikes in the
front yard you're back there with no
children everywhere it sounds like bait
kids at school huh no what are you
talking about me in the middle of the
day I was just hanging out doing jumping
my boy died I'm trying to fulfill his
dreams is somebody what I wanted
God damn Canaan oh man that's [__]
awesome dude out in Oregon with his RC
cars had something and then I get
because we're at a house I got my own
room I got uh a bunch of guitars that I
suck at I suck at everything like I'm
bad but I have multiple I'm guilty of
the guy like well if you buy a new one
you'll you'll learn yeah sure any of
those guitars hanging on the wall you
have them just in stand I got one of
them cool like boxes like the racks yeah
whoa really yeah like Coldplay yeah
[__] sweet like cold in case you need
to change you know what you need to
change guitars for the next song yeah
let's hear what Highway to Hell sounds
like if you only had two fingers
[Laughter]
and let's change guitars nine times
during this rendition that's [__]
funny
oh God okay uh how many suits do you own
and do you know how to tie a tie
uh
I actually have
four or five suits oh really because
when I was living in La we became
members of The Magic Castle
ah right so for the longest time you
have one suit in case somebody dies or
gets married but then when I start yeah
Court ah you don't want to look too
pretended you know you don't want to
look like you're coming all hoity toity
a shirt and a tie for court yeah or an
old like 90s suit like you're in there
in a Steve Harvey like my cousin Vinnie
or something
like yeah like like Suge Knight's coming
after me
but no then we so we got into like uh my
girlfriend got into magic a whole lot
and so we started going to the Magic
Castle which is like a country club for
magicians sure and you had to dress up
I'm like this is a reason to get suits
because now I can get a fun suit not a
suit that's just for like let me get
like a nice like a like a like a blue
with a Hawaiian shirt under it kind of
fun suit yeah so I I bought Formal Wear
to go watch Magic that's [__] funny
man the reason he buys suits is to go
see close-up man I wanted yeah I want to
feel nice that's crazy I get liquored up
and then
was taking magic classes and so she was
coming home but she was taking him there
and she'd have a few drinks and come
home with like a new magic trick and
she'd like do it on me but she was like
was like be drunk with a little attitude
and it was real hot because is this your
car she's like you [__] bet at your
card look at it like throwing it out I'm
getting turned on over here what I'm
into right now
but that's so I can enjoy Magic Man the
score is [__] racking up bro
I don't know if there's the caveats
because like oh too many suits not
garbage is it to see Illusions yeah you
bet it is yes yeah that's fine okay
let's talk about Helix Helix let's talk
about the best night's sleep that you're
ever gonna have gang you don't want to
be walking around a mattress store
figuring out what's what you can go over
to Helix take the Sleep quiz find out
exactly how you sleep they got a
mattress that'll perfectly match your
needs yeah guys it's fantastic like I
said for years they sent us uh they sent
me and my wife we took the two minutes
so you quiz they sent us the Twilight
model I love it she loves it I
masturbated earlier today I love it too
big dude what are you talking about uh
guys it's fantastic uh every Helix
mattress comes with a 15-year
manufacturer's warranty and that's in
addition to the 100 night trial you'll
get all with Helix mattresses they're
delivered straight to your door no more
going to the store in awkward lying on
mattresses in the middle of the
afternoon like a bozo yeah who wants to
do that Helix is offering uh 20 off all
matches orders and two free pillows for
our listeners go to helixsleep.com
garbage that's their best offer yet and
it won't last long so act now Helix
sleep.com slash garbage with Helix sleep
better with Helix better sleep starts
now plus I just found out to send to the
big man a mattress yay do it gang okay
let's talk about Bluetooth Let's Talk
About Sex baby this is for all you limp
noodles out there and let me tell you
you got one sitting right here we all
need a little help in the bedroom also
even if you don't have a limp noodle you
just want to [__] you want to stand
that attention baby huh you know what I
mean something to salute to it's not
really good something you can swing from
you want to give her something to miss
I'm talking about yeah it's no it's no
longer hard to get her it's no longer
hard to get or stay hard daddy uh enter
blue tube baby a unique online service
that delivers chewable Ed medicine right
to your your door to increase
performance and confidence it works baby
I put it on when I have important phone
calls I take it just for that extra
boosting
you got a big meeting coming up pop some
blue chew go in own the room
they won't be able to take their eyes
off to you I talk about always be
closing it's easy sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll get your
prescription in just days Bluetooth
tablets are made in the good old us
available I don't Outsource my hard-ons
I get them right here in America that's
right Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA like I just said and shipped and
discreet packaging now here we go baby
here's the turkey Bluetooth wants to
help you have better sex discover your
options at bluetooth.com chew it and do
it and we've got a special deal for our
listeners of Ru garbage try blue true
free when you use our promo code garbage
at checkout just paying five bucks for
shipping what are we talking about
you're in and out out the door five
bucks for boners that's bluetooth.com
promo code garbage to receive your first
month free visit bluetooth.com for more
details important safety information we
thank Bluetooth for sponsoring this
podcast the show back to the show do you
keep any pots and pans on the stove like
when they're not in use like as like
show pieces or is everything go in the
cabinet everything goes well when her
brother lived in the house before us and
he had one of those hangy things okay
wow so I it's just for storage for for
space spatial okay savings yeah that's
pretty clear that's pretty classy what's
the key what's the key situation with
Kyle Kinane how many keys do you have no
they're on a carabiner you look like a
carabiner kind of guy I got three
carabiners I got a van keys
and also because like I
I think it's like a smidge OCD so I've
got to have a house key on each thing
really so I got I got a set of bike keys
with various bike locks sure I got a set
for the van and various locks within the
van for there's uh bike racks in the van
with locks and also uh gun safe what do
you have on your right now like is it
just none because I'm out in just you
know I got a hotel Key all right that's
perfect and then put that on a Caribbean
yeah that's not bad but yeah so I got
you said gun safe what kind of nickel
you got some nickel out there
yeah I got a couple pieces what do you I
don't know anything about guns but I'm
intrigued neither do I but it's just
I got a bazooka sometimes you just want
to flex those constitutional rights you
know
sure yeah I mean you're out there in the
woods theoretically yeah yeah that's
where I go to shoot yeah I got a I got a
nine millimeter and 40 cal okay 40 cal
40 cal that sounds heavy bike it's
that's a big boy no it's it's got a
little funked is it for yeah not yeah
four yeah 40 calories is anything on the
ready at the house in case somebody
would come snooping around
or do you got to get the you got to go
to the garage with the Carabiner no get
the [__] gun key and go into the safe
and get it no you sleep with like a bat
or anything
no okay home protection there's like
this is how much do I wanna we're like
in the van I have a machete and a
hatchet okay well because when I was
like I was like when I was killing
people
[Laughter]
did something quick
a machete well like I'd park the van I
was out for seven weeks that first
summer and I was like I didn't I didn't
know were you talking like where were
you parked like
Walmarts were safe yeah Walmart's fun
now that everybody lives in their van
and it's not just like let's welcome
these retirees that'll be cross-country
they're like oh hold on now people now
this has its own ZIP code yeah and so
those were safer but there was I
remember I was going through Austin I
parked in front like okay I'm gonna hang
out the creek in the cave I'll drink I
can just go to sleep out here
there's a dicey over there and I was
just laying in the van like
it's just a matter of time before this
window gets smashed in and so sure
you know Mental Health crisis comes in
and I'm gonna like I don't know if I
could do it I've never been in a fight I
do this man
I love these are never been a fight I
got a 40 cal a sniper rifle three
machetes that's what you do and you
don't know how to fight
I'll say because you can't do it on your
own very true that is a very good point
I've just got a laser painter yeah I've
got a coward's armament
holy [__] dude I mean you are something
else man
um when's the last time you got a
massage you do massages at all
um you treat yourself can I go I don't
know if this qualifies under the
checklist it's not gonna be classy
whatever it is I don't do massages but I
do get my ears waxed okay okay with the
with the the honeycomb thing or like the
outside no I go to a place they put the
hot wax and pull the ear out the ear
hair yeah okay yeah because they were
getting like that's not a massage but
all right well that's I'm like like I'm
like is it self-care does it fun yeah
that's that's grooming it's like clearly
like like my neck like this will Loop
together eventually and I'm fine but for
some reason ear hair yeah like I have
enough ear hair that it just rejects air
pods oh wow immediately
[Music]
they don't connect because they don't
feel the skin no and it's like the way
it's like it's like white blonde hair so
they just look blurry
man I have I've started to have to get
that done too and I for the first time I
went and got my nose hair done which I
was always warned about that it can get
infected but dude it's you're good for
like six weeks cleans it all right out
we uh my girlfriend and I she had like
the little Wax Kit at home it was years
ago like oh yeah let's like do the noses
and it was wild because like if you just
put it on a Q-tip yeah that's not
something you do with it and it just
looks like like an old dandelion when it
comes out puts all the hair on it but
then my mom had gotten Us gift
certificates for indoor skydiving
and so we went and did that right after
we did the nose hair and you don't
realize how much nose hair keeps things
in yeah and so we're just indoor
skydiving and we both just had so much
snot just flying up the sides of our
faces like you want to buy your photos
like I'll pay you to burn those I'll
tell you to never show those pictures to
somebody again holy [__] but uh massage
and I don't know it's been a while okay
um any vacations recently you and you
and the misses get away you go anywhere
wherever we go it's been yeah yeah we
went out to we went to Hawaii back in uh
very nice where'd you go what island uh
this last time was Kauai okay a bunch of
times I love it yeah a bunch of times to
Hawaii I love it my girl uh my girl's
from there she's from Oahu oh yeah we go
about once a year last uh four or five
years you go back to Ohio you got other
spots we go we always go back to Oahu
because that's where that's where the
family is and we went to the Big Island
this trip that we just went and I gotta
tell you I wasn't crazy about it really
I'm I'm a Oahu guy it's like a Farm
Island yeah I like I like the little mix
of the city and a little mix of the
beach and all that stuff oh man we went
to Kauai nice it's beautiful over there
this might be trashy we let a stray cat
into the Airbnb for the week we got it
there we are I think it had me only you
could make Hawaii trashy Canaan
it's their place now and the last day we
were there was in the house and I think
like like a breeze or something locked
into the bathroom and it took the
nastiest [__] on the bathroom floor and
when it's an Airbnb so you gotta clean
everything and we're leaving and nobody
even touched the bathrooms it was the
worst smelling [__]
oh man that's [__] all right I don't
know if we got the deposit I would say
no uh what's your favorite flavor of
Gatorade
oh
favorite I mean I don't like because now
there's like black ice there's a bunch
yeah there's like there's not black guys
there's not all right that's an air
pressure air freshener to you black guys
all right that's what you want to call
me on is that I didn't know that that
wasn't
no you're wow no but that yourself a
couple of points for that you're [__]
jerks
[__] I'm not gonna be sitting here and
judged on my guess this dip [__] thinks
black ice is a Gatorade flavor there
probably is one very close to that
something that sounds like a like a
Wesley Snipes character or something
I don't know red I got like I go I'm old
school like it was bright green yeah and
it was red
and black ice is a Gatorade flavor by
the way
[Laughter]
extra points or take points off what are
whatever had again
but that never happened black ice was
the name of the cat we led into the
airplane
Fierce black cherry ice I'll give you
that that's it that's [__] awesome
that's so funny I was like dude that's
too close that probably could be a name
for the [__] win
he just took our 40 calibers
it oh
uh okay any of your family members get
married at the courthouse
family no okay okay friends yeah yeah
okay yeah
my one buddy it was a courthouse it was
a zoom wedding that I forgot about my
best friend from back home and seeing
the zoom I was there man you got the
sport coat on you wearing shorts
I got those suits you know
um
let me ask you this how do you feel
about the rotisserie chicken before when
you were eating meat love it yeah I just
love it one of the best purchases you
can make 8.99 or whatever that's all
right immediate food immediate good food
you could put it in tortillas and put it
in a pita make a little sandwich out of
it put it on a salad if you want to be
healthy a little bit hot dogs are being
ready to go love rotisserie chicken okay
I knew I liked you
um when you uh say it's just you and
your girl if you would make spaghetti
all right do you cook the whole box of
pasta and use the whole jar of sauce yes
okay yeah
that's leading the witness your honor I
do this every single time you said him
and his girl that was never the argument
right it was you it was just you if it
was yours okay you'd still you'd still
cook the whole and leave the leftovers
in the fridge yes gentlemen okay I'll
throw this tip on there too I used to
cook the pasta heat up the sauce put the
sauce on the cooked pasta this is what I
learned from Mrs
you heat up the sauce cook the pasta put
the pasta in the sauce that's hot Stir
It Around Stir It Cooks into it a little
bit that's real is she Italian no that's
a real old school right there she just
knows she's cultured yeah do you sleep
with your socks on
no what are you sleeping not much just
maybe your bare bones a lot of fun a lot
of free manscaped Underpants
shout out to him God did you have you
gotten to that point yet like like where
you're just surrounded with swag like I
have like I still like I've been trying
to work out but like I'm like I was
getting into bed one night I realized
I'm wearing like these manscape panties
and my Dr my dressers got like gout
medicine on it I'm like I'm the least
[__] person that's ever lived why
are you here
yeah I'm at that point too my yeah my no
offense to manscape that I use the
products shout out to them they got they
got the nose trimmer too I wouldn't do
the wax I'd use the nose trimmer for
manscape shout out to the 2.0
um what the sleeping situation you got a
king-sized bed you got a queen size bed
what are you what are you using over
there um we had to up it to
a California king because I snore so
much whoa this was the largest size
before we moved to sleeping in separate
rooms okay and I did a sleep study and I
don't have sleep apnea and it was one of
the most disappointing things so I don't
qualify for a seat path through
Insurance do you breathe through your
mouth or your nose I have all of it all
of it I [__] snore if I do crossword
puzzles and I think too hard if I'm like
looking down at an angle and they
wouldn't give a kid
I went to the place with all the nodes
and everything and I woke up the next
day and the guy's like yeah you snore
like a [__] but it's not the
numbers for them like well fudge the
numbers man yeah juice the books I'm
trying to stay with my especially here
dude yeah I woke up after one of our
vacations where it was like two weeks of
her not sleeping I just woke up to her
punching the headboard next to my face
like I can't [__] take this anymore
it's tough man what what
are you using anything for that because
they have the mouth pieces and stuff
like that yeah I did that and it felt
like my teeth were gonna fall away yeah
slanted pillow the mouthpiece the strips
I got some spray okay so what I use is
giving her earplugs yeah my wife does
the same thing it's got the California
gang yeah which is pretty sweet you fall
asleep with the TV on and you turn the
TV off or you go to bed no TV in the
bedroom no TV in the bedroom so when you
like that you go to bed no microwave
yeah just we're just out there living
hunting no I respect that I respect that
too no no no TV in the bed but I gotta
listen to
I listen like podcasts about ghosts or
something sure fall asleep you fall
asleep in your ear I got the special
headband with the flat speakers okay it
rules
and it's flat so you can lay on the side
of your head
oh dude I had one and it was shitty so I
had like spent a hundred bucks on like a
good headband
so I could sleep
picture of you snoring damn on you got
the manscaped on design it's I am the
least [__] man
pulling the earbuds it's just like oh
and then there was orbs they saw in the
basement
that's all right Bigfoot's real it sure
is
um if you're the living embodiment of
you don't quit skateboarding because you
get old you get old because you quit
Escape dude yeah I have I've preserved
myself he's the man I just I like my
reflection's upsetting
other than that I'm killing it catch
myself lacing up my Vans and putting on
some board shorts to go have a whirl on
the BMX bike and then gas up my car's
neck up as a substitute teacher I had to
go back to work
um when you do fly uh will you put the
seat back
yeah you will yeah will you give a peek
will you ask anything you're just
dropping back no just going back taking
the shoes off on the plane
no but usually I'm wearing Crocs anyway
okay Crush out the Crocs and socks Crocs
and socks on the plane I'm not gonna go
barefoot there's nothing more
comfortable than a pair of Crocs with
socks on it's it's literally the old I
can't bring myself to do it ah they're
great can't be that guy will you bring
food on the plane with you will you
bring like a sandwich or anything
no I've I've locked down air travel to
where I can like it's the closest to
being a private jet is where if like I
drive or anything I get off I could walk
through I got the timing down to walk
through where I never even have to sit
in the airport walk right on the plane
okay really usually no food usually I
must sleep okay I take red eyes and
stuff so I snorted on the plane the
whole way out here yeah
I knew I was stored too I'll get that
almost loosen point where I'm like not
all the way asleep but I know I'm
snoring but I'm like I'm pretty tired
though so sorry everybody you wake up
you feel like you were just ignored you
can like physically feel like I was just
selling wood the one good thing I'll say
about the plane is the noise the natural
like room tone on the plane it covers it
up a little bit we'd like to think that
wouldn't we yeah
yeah we would we sure would like to
think that he woke me up I was snoring
the last flight we were on yo you also
wake up panicking was I snoring I'm like
dude [__] take Alexa Pro or something
Jesus it's the opposite of a TR if a
tree falls in the forest like well if
I'm snoring but I can't hear it because
I'm the one snoring am I even saying did
it even happen yes you are uh have you
ever bought uh any As Seen On TV
products I think the headphone things
the sleep mask yeah I bought a few of
those I got the not The Slap Chop but
the big uh
the one was like it was like a grid
blade so you like slap you'd smashed
like chop your dice your vegetables
yeah I got a salad spinner
shout out to the salad spinner that had
a run for a little while they kind of
fell off a little bit those things are
great it was fun to use yeah I got yeah
I'm on my second one I had the the like
the mower start one and the cord broke
because I like the dry salad
I don't like any moisture on my leaves
well I'm coming out crisp and then I I
got uh what I fell for like some
targeted ad on Instagram too I got but
um it's a rope belt that's just an old
piece of climbing rope but it's a belt
okay and it's just
it's a piece of rope and it's looped on
one end with a little grippy thing yeah
they got you they got it and it's again
that probably only went to you yeah
they're like let's get Canadian they
were young in the storage room like we
sold one yeah we got new colors Kyle I'm
using my first name
and that is one of the ones from like
one I showed it to my girlfriend just
once and she's like absolutely never let
me see that really all right well
whatever wear that when I'm alone yeah
well that goes back to the Crocs thing I
don't know if I told the story
last time about how we had to go to a
beach wedding and it was like get casual
lay it on us sure they were like get
like oh it's a beach wedding so it's
like casual but you know weddings I want
to surfboard I found a thing called
flofers I'm Googling those they're
rubber loafers they're loafers that
float loafers and I was like this is
exactly what these are for I get drunk
and fall in the ocean this is exactly
what these are made for these yeah
they're not that big they're not okay
all right I'm on your uh
I wanted this on paper by the name
flofer you should be wrong but that's
okay that's all right I thought I was
nailing it for a beach wedding and I get
them and I was like babe for the beach
wedding you're never gonna believe it
[__] no said like it's the only time she
said send them back now and that's how I
got my first pair of Crocs is because
she felt bad that she made me send those
back oh so she bought me Crocs that
looks that's better than Crocs yeah
they're not that bad man
you're throwing a pair of khakis you go
to the beach listen that's fine I'm here
to tell you that we're all wrong
this episode has been brought to you by
floaters according to a woman that
tastes we are that we all we know why
those are
fitting the task at hand it's not
egregious obviously they're not the
coolest looking shoe but that's not
egregious yeah it's a loafer my wife
would give me [__] for that I was ready
for the beach
formal it's a Croc it's loafers it's a
formal Aqua sock that's what it is let's
go uh-huh will you fart an Uber yeah
okay
I mean like not like loud but like once
you crack the window They Know What You
Did you'll crack the window you
gentlemen I wait I see like what
elevation it gets to sure if it's a low
liar if it's like a
that's Like An American Werewolf in
London Fog and it's just you know
waist-high I'll leave it but if it
starts getting up if it's simmering up
like a like a if it's midnight in the
tower London
it's like kind of a nice food smell you
where you're like okay we'll crack the
cracked yeah
um when you're getting dressed do you
put
your socks on and then your pants or
your pants and then your socks
socks then pants but it's a real
free-for-all okay
I've yeah I've [__] up the order
sometimes but you will lend you will
lead socks first
usually socks first okay okay but
I respect I'm uh I'm a real shorts guy
as much as I can be if I'm not going out
so really sometimes socks aren't part of
the equation on account of the Crocs or
the flow first yeah I mean what a name
floaters they're all right how do you
feel about the deviled egg love it okay
absolutely love it what are you putting
on it uh green olive a little green
olive maybe a little paprika I would say
a little paprika a little color to it
you know keep it pretty simple little
mayo little Dijon mustard maybe a splash
of hot sauce mix a little hot sauce in
with the yolk yeah it's really good all
right all about deviled eggs all right
ties right into that farting in the Uber
all right respective yes it does
uh all right let's do one from patreon
this is from Grizz Adams never have one
read when was the last time you cooked
without a shirt on I think all the time
yeah yeah I feel like you're a loose
form of cooking yeah I did open that
canister is assembling
what if they what if the absence of heat
will you eat over the sink yeah and when
you and your girl eat do you guys when
you guys are home if you're off the road
she's home you make dinner will you sit
down at the table and eat or you guys
sit in front of the couch and watch TV
no we sit at the table you do we gotta
yeah it's set up
situation like sit and watch TV okay and
uh we did get in the habit though of
like oh if we're eating I don't know I
don't think it's racist but we would
like play music from whatever country
food we were eating no that's nice no
you're something like that but then
there's like a staycation yeah but then
there's moments where you're like
I can't do any more of this
I disco that you found on Spotify like
yeah we'll both be sitting there eating
like
it's a bit much put on the stones or
something let's go like I'm really
enjoying this massaman Curry but uh
that's pretty cool
some real warbling coming out of the
Bluetooth right now
that's pretty that is like an elevated
way to experience it is doing an extra
fun thing yeah for sure of course I
respect that man found some pretty fun
stuff there is I think it's like it's
like there's like this Cambodian Funk
scene from the 70s
put a favorite put the thumbs up on this
I want to listen to this again all right
man
Ah that's [__] funny uh what kind of
deodorant are you using
not I mean Old Spice I got it I got a
stick of Old Spice that I'm probably on
year three okay you don't do deodorant
no really it makes me
it makes me it makes me sweat more
like it never does the job and
if I like if I'm getting real funky all
right okay let's throw a little on
I'm kind of like yeah I'm kind of into
my own musk well I'm like one of those I
don't hate that is it but I some people
does it become an issue like do people
go like I've been told I've ruined I've
ruined parts of the house whoa
man this guy plays by his own rules
nickname becomes onion patch sometimes
it's wild man do you wear any cologne or
anything
no no and what's what's soapy somebody's
doing the first line of defense but I do
have my moisturize you do yeah whoa I
even have like the little under eye
thing
you know I need them
what's the soap in the shower is it a
bar is it uh it's probably pine cones
and Elmer's Glue yeah I mean well it's
that Dr Bronner so pretty much that's
pretty much
same thing they're all right just black
ice Gatorade a couple drops of Palmolive
in it put some armor on the wheels I'm
calling today overall for the outer bits
for the shine get the deluxe get the
works and keep it moving baby
will you do the venmo instant transfer
like if somebody said venmoji 100 bucks
will you instantly translated to your
bank account or you do like the one to
three business days one to three
business days nobody's getting a cut of
my money it doesn't deserve a cut of my
money really I'm instant transfer all
day these old school JG Wentworth it's
my money and I need it now Bobby I pay
off all my credit cards right away I'm
like I do that I love it I love the idea
like no you're not getting [__] out of
my Capital One nothing is that what
you're throwing around thanks for the
points is that where you're throwing
around Capital One you got an Amex I got
uh I'll break it down like for business
as soon as I leave yeah this is big as
soon as I leave the house for anything
work related I have one credit card so I
don't keep receipts that credit card
payment goes to the accountant great
everything I bought on this is for
business good and then I have another
one that's just for my [__] that's
like a MasterCard it's like an REI card
because you know you're going to REI
like I might need all this stuff if the
[__] goes down sure and then I bought
all that stuff I don't use it okay I
like it I like it that's pretty good I
might need to buy a kayak ore
to beat somebody
just sharpen the edge so it's not
technically a weapon
huh have you ever written your name in
wet cement yes
sounds like you've done that recently a
couple times well I haven't been by wet
cement recently but if I was I would do
you have flashlights in the house oh
yeah you have binoculars in the house
yeah you do and I got telescope now you
do have a telescope
I'm doing a whole bit about it I love a
telescope I got it with my credit card
points
I'll show you Capital One
you got getting [__] out of me if it's
like my dick I'm looking at Saturn this
weekend is it that good a one yeah yeah
it's Bonkers really yeah does it have
like the audio the like the auto
tracking it's all manual but it was like
a pandemic thing I'm like all right
because that's something they're like
well
Jupiter and Saturn are gonna be next to
each other and it's I remember that and
it's you can't see the details but the
fact that it's just I just got a tube
yeah with glass and mirrors in it it's
pretty sweet and I was in the alley at
that time we're in the apartment in LA
and I'm in the alley in the apartment
and I could see like I said I could see
that with the ring around and I'm like
I'm looking at this thing just in an
alley it's wild
it's wild perspective changes I found an
old one during the pandemic at my
parents house and it was it was a little
wonky I could only see the moon but when
you honed in on that thing the detail
you're like holy [__] that thing is
really that ain't made out of cheese
it's wild man I respect it it's it like
it's less like you see the thing then
it's kind of yeah you put yourself into
a place like you get like philosophical
yeah and so I'm just looking for UFOs I
want to see something going across the
news of course have you ever has anybody
in your family ever claimed to see UFO
or Sasquatch uh uh well I'm in that
world so not not my family so I'm the
one who's claimed this I uh I got close
to thinking I saw a UFO in San Francisco
has turned out like the Chinese lanterns
that they let go connected because I'm
like it's a pattern what's over there
and like a drunk on a roof I'm like yes
I'm seeing a UFO and not any of the very
logical things drunk on a roof yeah I
saw right over Chinatown is it the lamps
that they used no it couldn't be it
couldn't be it's got to be
extraterrestrials oh man would you would
you be stoked if you saw a UFO or would
you be or make you nervous
now would you report it okay well no no
now we're on my turf guys
buddy we've been on your Thursday for
the past 45 minutes I don't know if
you've been listening
we're in kyleville right now
[Laughter]
with the rubber dress shoes and the gun
came inside and he saw aliens yeah
I think I I mean I think it depends on
the context of what would happen is it
is it I think I'd be more mystified I'd
like to say that but then truly knowing
myself I'd probably get scared [__] I
feel like I'd kill myself I'd be so
nervous I think the anxiety of not
knowing anything I'd [__] lose my
mind I think I'm I'm feeling it oh for
me thanks of course give him another one
he's on a roll
about to start talking about Bigfoot
I don't think I'm getting you another
beer and then do you have theories on
Bigfoot as well
I you know what I think that's right
that's fun I got a good idea
Cooper country I solved DB Cooper baby
what do you think I just saw something I
saw another something on it as well
having done little to no research that's
the best
I think the flight crew did it
whoa did anybody
check the flight Crews back so nobody
saw the guy
the whole story was made up by the
flight crew that's pretty so if all the
flight crew was just like West for a
reasonable amount we'd break off a piece
we threw a parachute out a few bucks out
to lead them off none of the passengers
know right and then
they probably weren't vetted at the
point that at that point they just ran
with the story like the authorities yeah
and just that's pretty good so he never
existed the FL they all got some money
not an exorbitant amount but enough
money to be like all right this helps us
all out nobody got hurt
hmm that's my that's my and I'll tell
you what they came up one of the coolest
mysterious names of all time DB Cooper
shout out to it DB yeah the sunglasses
and everything yeah and the drawing of
like uh
man I don't know draw a guy just a guy
yeah he had on a suit and uh sunglasses
I could see that like the end of Ocean's
11 man the flight Crews walking the
Baseline kicks in yeah you get 20
sticking out of the bag yeah there was
no DT Cooper that's my uh that's my
theory on that but I don't know I did
not know if they if the police had
investigated the crew for this okay so I
would assume the FBI probably did at
some point that's all right I don't know
but maybe back then you know the
suspicion wasn't really up yeah it was
one of the kind of the first time
something like that happened more scared
about like oh he's making on me said
he's got a bomb he's got to land the
plane here and get it refueled but he's
letting the passengers go and then he
jumped out midair that's pretty good I
hope there's an FBI guy listening to
this doing a u-turn on a highway
[Laughter]
calling a secretary I think I cracked a
DB Cooper case and get me a pair of
loafers
call my wife
will you dance in a way
were you dancing or whatever you cut her
up you will yeah could you do the worm
as a kid I bet you were a worm I could
do it wow I could do a worm I couldn't
do any other any other moves though no
like no pop and lock or anything sure
yeah the worms all you need girlfriend's
a big dancer and I was like I had this
Revelation out of the way I'm like wait
a minute I was the guy who would sit
there and I wouldn't dance because I'm
like look at all these people yeah they
look silly and I'm like flipped it and
I'm like you're alone yeah you're able
yeah on your ninth free drink and it's
also like everybody's cool yeah that's
me everybody knows what you're doing
yeah everybody's like that guy's sitting
there because he's yeah ashamed to dance
I Don't Dance everything's dancing yeah
especially at a wedding so now I'm like
absolutely yeah it's a whole time at a
wedding yeah I'll give it to you huh
okay let's do another one from patreon
here this is from Dawson I don't know I
don't I don't think anybody has ever
said yeses but you could be the guy have
you ever attempted to do a local
restaurants eating challenge
the old 86 or anything like that you
know the 37 hot dogs in under an hour
some man versus food type I did I was on
hot ones a few years ago
I doubled down on the hottest sauce you
did yeah you can take that kind of heat
I used to be able to I don't kill
anymore
I hung my gun up now I just cut myself
to feel some you know let me tell you
something let me tell you something fat
boy
that's gonna open no [__] yeah I I
haven't done because that's not [__]
around hot on that show those things are
hot no it it it
went for it but one of the things I did
here and you might be able to weigh in
on this you're the first person I asked
about it who's done the show is they say
by like I don't know let's say there's
like six of them or what is there 10 or
whatever it was 10 yeah let's say about
like five they're like it's already so
hot that like incrementally yeah it's
like diminishing returns it's like
you're adding time to how long it's
gonna be yeah it's gonna get hotter it's
you're just gonna be more uncomfortable
for a longer kind of like when you're
wet you're wet here's a question I
always had about that show how are the
wings
I was I was doing the veggie thing which
I addressed at the beginning I'm like
everybody uh log into the comments and
call me a [__] how are the veggie Wings
fine I mean it was just a means to it
was just a distribution it's a vehicle
yeah so because the wings look pretty
good on that show and I'm like again I
still like all the food like I still I
don't look at meat like I just had you
know gout and all this other my own like
let me do these things for health sure I
did it for health you know
he's chugging day beers blood Heavies
but uh I did also I had um
there's a place called Holland race in
L.A it's a Hot Chicken Spot Nashville
Hot Chicken okay and I didn't do a
challenge but I did do like it was a
personal challenge but yeah well they
had like you know that's one place that
I'll break Edge and get like a sandwich
from here really but they're like oh
it's medium and hot and then like
suicide the crazy one I'm like well
maybe I'll just get the sandwich hot and
I'll try a wing that's the crazy one and
the guy was just matter of fact he's
like I'm just gonna tell you right now
that the hot ones we make with rubber
gloves this many peppers goes into it
people don't finish those the hot one
I don't know why we make that one really
I'm like all right let me backtrack let
me get a medium sandwich in One Wing of
their hot and I ate that
and the guy also he gave me time frames
like hot
that's about two to four hours in your
day God damn the crazy Isaac that's six
to eight hours of your day
like just said like of what just no this
is how much your Days Doctor yeah it
just said it's so matter of factly not
like I dare you to do it yeah all right
just give me one wing of the hot one and
it was four hours to be like really
just ruin your day like I might start
praying
's wild
oh man uh is another food one uh you're
a great great trashy food Guy this is
from Joshua uh is it garbage gonna make
nachos with Cool Ranch Doritos
or have you ever thought of that yeah
[Laughter]
I mean I would only object because I
think
once again like the vehicle thing
nachos are about the flavors you're
putting on it true the chip already has
flavor kind of stepping on toes a little
sure it might be Overkill but I like
this guy seems like a free thinker and I
encourage him to go forward with it
that's my DB Cooper theory
if you make do you do nachos at the
house or or what are you a nacho guy I
do have a couple cans when I got the hot
dogs in the can I do have
that was also that same little area and
I was I I didn't have cheese I was gonna
make nachos the other day but I didn't
have cheese for it uh yeah yeah I'll
[__] around nachos oh you know microwave
so what do you through the oven put them
in the oven what's a no microwave all
about just the lifestyle thing no we
just didn't the old apartment had one
that was like above the stove when we
moved we didn't get one and it was like
let's see how long we can go without it
because it was like it was also pandemic
it's like it's not we're not in a rush
sure yeah you don't need to save four
minutes you know so like this is the
close like I was thinking like this will
jump start me into becoming a chef there
you go now that guy it all started when
I didn't get to buy a mic because now I
gotta heat up chili in a pan yeah oh my
god get the apron and the Big Chef
Boyardee head out over here uh
uh-huh I always wanted breakfast nachos
I thought those could be made
I like it I've had them have you I
believe so maybe it's just kind of like
oh you're like yeah chili Achilles
is that's all right I've had a man
what's that at norms I get them at
Norm's when we're in L.A thanks Toby
we're gonna ruin everything
always again somebody should make this
oh they do oh you're right
will you do karaoke
will you do karaoke and do you have a
go-to song uh I'll joke right now but I
I love calling the karaoke okay but it's
a punishment to people sure like I don't
sing
well
but I'd also okay but it's like I sing
so bad it's upsetting I think I would be
that I sing like the like turn the
volume down bad like it's happened to me
at karaoke I'm like well I'll just put
on a show and be like oh man they turned
the volume down so I'm like I'm there
because I love seeing people have that
kind of fun sure if like we're going out
we're gonna go to karaoke like yeah I
want to see people get into it I'm not
it's not like dancing where everything's
dancing and you're just it's like no
this affects somebody else's happiness
of Mo everybody else in the bar and it's
not like I know that too because you
know you see when somebody's bad
everybody's kind of laughing or they're
into it with them and I'm like the get
up and go and get a drink like I'm
taking five yeah let's have a smoke this
is this is upsetting so I don't sing it
Karen okay uh okay in the past 365 days
have you pooped at a bar
oh yeah
okay does there have to be specific
conditions or yeah I have to poop
sometimes I'll leave the house to poop
at a bar what if there's no door on the
stall
um
will you try to mask or you do anything
because or you're just like go in there
you're like who are you willing to go
was what we're at all the way really
it's got a machete in a van yeah that's
true
places that I've been to that don't have
doors anymore though
it's kind of stepped up I like that I'm
not hanging out in places with the doors
in the bathroom that's pretty good yeah
huh it's pretty good uh
what are you thinking here
I mean I got the I got a uh I got a few
more uh challenge me man oh I would like
to is it do you call it hamburger meat
or ground beef or a new one taco meat
don't let me mean a new one well that's
the new one not to you what a new one
it's where is it going okay but if you
say I'm running to the store it'll it'll
be and it'll just be what are you making
with yeah if you're just like I would
like to have some meat on hand
that's ground beef okay ground beef oh
we're gonna make hamburgers I'll go get
some hamburger meat okay
I'll go get some taco meat okay okay
fair enough this one's from Rodrigo uh
never had one red is it garbage put
mustard on burns my mom's been doing
this since she worked at Mickey D's in
the early 2000s
hey can I get a look on that is that
something mustard on burns like if you
get a burn if you're I guess a cooking
burn or something you put mustard on it
there's got to be something in it Jesus
I would assume what
there's no scientific evidence
supporting mustard as a remedy for minor
burns you calling this kid's mom a liar
yes
I want to know where your mom is from I
can't put Big Mac sauce on an open wound
although although differentiating
opinions but this does come from the
national mustardmuseum.com that's
big mustard but that means people have
been asking
this isn't like one guy whose mom was
into voodoo
it's like dude we it's like DB Cooper we
may never know the answer uh it's
because uh there's turmeric in the
mustard which is anti-inflammatory okay
come on okay I don't know there had to
be based on something that's pretty good
um
but that's that's because she worked at
McDonald's that's what she did I guess
she I guess it was an old McDonald's uh
wives tale
Jesus McDonald's is so hardcore like
nobody's going to hospital
everybody play it cool and put your foot
in the McFlurry machine you gotta burn
mustard goes on it the sniffles Jam some
ketchup up your ass
we take care of problems in-house the
clown doesn't like it if we talk we're
switching over from breakfast to lunch
we need you people walking around with
pickles on their eyes
uh what do you leave for the for the
hotel when uh for the uh
um the cleaning chamber mate yeah if
that's the right term I uh per night
I never let him come into the room I'm
not an animal I like pick up after
myself I I respect I'm trying to leave a
Fiverr at the end but it sucks because
if I don't have cash on me I do not know
why you cannot add a gratuity to your to
your building that's very good and I
think what it is is that maybe a lot of
the
people working in the hotel are
undocumented and so there's no tax
recourse for them sure that's why the
cash has that gotcha that makes sense
but okay you can get change from the
front desk and you go and leave I leave
a Fiverr okay what are you guys leaving
uh it depends per night you're doing
Fiverr per night Fiverr like if it's a
road gig of three nights and I never
they don't come in okay I just leave a
five right at the end of the weekend
okay because they're only coming in ones
okay I try to do uh it depends I I've
mentioned this before for a very long
time we didn't have any money and I
would not stiff anybody but just short
so yeah I'll do if I'm in there for a
night depending on how much I clean up
or what it is uh or if there's like
7-Eleven trash or whatever uh five to
ten okay because I have no get I want to
know if I need to step up my game it
should be about a dull box yeah you
could go you could you could ten bucks I
think if they're not coming in they're
just cleaning up on the I think 10 bucks
is it okay I don't have a lot of merch
cat like from the shows too okay I gotta
step up my game then little bit I will I
mean I put my trash in the trash
sometimes I have not done that if I wake
up hungover I'm like [__] we're running
late it's yeah I try to Corral stuff to
where to be together it's by the truck I
didn't real I always use like a like one
of the towels as a napkin I'm like oh I
should be using a makeup towel for that
there's a reason sure there's a reason
it's the not covered I steal those a lot
I steal makeup towels yeah you take
anything if it's a different color I'll
take that I'll bring it home for the
bird let her do it for her makeup how
much do you leave after that listen I
took a lot of [__] from here I took two
paintings in the norm
will you use the coffee maker in a hotel
room absolutely you will absolutely whoa
I've uh that's a wild man right there
yeah I've uh oh I've done weird [__] I
didn't I I yeah I've absolutely drinked
out of the coffee out of the coffee
maker I did uh the worst is I tried to
heat up pizza using the hair dryer once
what the [__] man were you drunk or
something in a society dude I just was
like I'm stuck eating this because I'll
get like one extra large pizza I like
the weekend love them and I'll just
Revenant that [__] for the next three
days very good move but it was like
getting a little rough towards like
Saturday I'm like should we hit it with
the hair dryer for a while holy let me
blow some hot pubes on this
you know what this means nut smell
[Laughter]
hold on we've opened up a little door
here so you are okay with getting a
pizza yeah and leaving it out yeah for
multiple days yeah okay yeah I respect
that as well I'm still here man yeah I
don't think no two day old Pizza it's it
hits a little different in the morning
or whatever it's I love it it's one of
my go-to's you can put it on like top of
the AC if it's hot out
sure oh my God
hit it with the iron it's all right
do you have any baking soda in your
fridge or freezer at the house I think
it's been in there since we moved in
good landlords
back to the hotel will you use the
ironing board as a table to eat have you
ever utilized that trick it's a good
move dude no that's great you pull you
can sit on the side of the bed you pull
the you pull the ironing board up no
I've since like Thanksgiving dinner baby
and do you like a hotel or are you more
of an Airbnb guy I love a hotel I love a
hotel this is like travel she likes to
take an Airbnb understand because you're
like in a neighborhood everything
chores no at the end of my vacation I
agree I'm alone if it's like one
king-sized bed or two queen size bed you
give me two
one for sleep and one for eating sure
respect that's a gentlemen's move right
there gentlemen's move okay uh
uh I'll do that to do what I want to do
more from patreon here this one's from
RJ I thought about the van this is good
uh it's even this is just a fun fun time
I took an RV to my junior prom hear me
out though we had about 20 kids and beer
in the refrigerator it was like a house
party on wheels that ain't bad that's a
[__] good time tailgated your problem
that's way better than a limo or [__]
whatever it absolutely is just doing
some laps hanging out in an RV have you
taken a limo or a party bus anywhere
I have yeah I mean I
Lim like prom but like limo not in on
purpose
what's the last time you were in a limo
have you ever got one sent like someone
sent in a car or whatever and they
sometimes they do that they end up just
being like owls we have is available no
for like I mean like when I was in LA
and if you were like if I was doing like
at midnight or something they'd send a
car for you and it was like those
Lincolns where it's not all the way
stretched
yeah throw the feet out I'm like you
don't see a lot of limos zipping around
anymore it's not a thing yeah it's weird
do you ever do you have a rider
no we were just talking about we're just
talking about right I do and it needs to
be augmented because I had it when I was
doing like it's still just like chicken
wings
well it's it's said from like when I was
doing smaller music venues myself yeah
just one honey baked ham
and a hatchet that's it trust me I'll
get it done
what's the machete yeah I got I brought
my own don't worry I got my own shot
because the music then the music venues
are big on the Riders
if I was dry like because then I was
doing a different city every night so
I'd be driving
you know anywhere from five to seven
hours every day two quarts of oil oil
[Laughter]
you gotta hook up with BF Goodrich I'm
gonna need a
right but so I'm like okay and you like
all Road Foods trash and then I get
there like I wanna I just I I still want
to sleep in and I drive right to the
venue
I don't want to eat a bunch of shitty
food so I'm like it needs to be like
like veggie platters and trail mix like
stuff that's good for me because the
only time I'm gonna eat something decent
for myself is in that moment and so then
I'll have that I'm like oh I'm not
starving I ate all this
my carrot sticks and everything and then
I just you know smart get the pizza at
the end of the night okay so that was
that is my rider but then plays them
like I tell them like it's very minimal
I want the dumbest like the shittiest
little veggie platter from Albertsons
with the carrots and the thing and the
ranch in the middle like you go to
places like here's a freshly sliced like
at home just give me the Eight dollar
one yeah the one that was marked down
yeah yeah something that expired a
little cherry tomatoes in the celery
give me though yeah celery can get the
[__] out of here
room temperature ice yeah
oh
wait that's what you're calling tower
that took me a minute they're calling it
room temperature ice oh [__] wow man he
is a Wordsmith man that's a [__] take
right there room temperature ice you
know it makes a little sense yeah
because it's like nothing yeah some
people call it crunchy water I go the
other way with room temperature there
you go I'll give you that uh all right I
got one more for patreon this was from
MRI is it garbage if you have a tooth
pulled instead of getting the proper
dental work to save the tooth he said
hey I got 50 bucks not 1200 for the root
canal I've been there have you ever
bypassed any medical or dental procedure
do you have all your teeth yeah it looks
like oh I got a couple wisdom teeth
taken out okay it looks like you got
good teeth though you got a good set of
jobs all the other stuff yeah but teeth
are still going to slap into a dentist
in uh five years yeah I'm up there too
floss every day
oh no no like it's like you take that
back like every couple of weeks where
I'm like let's get in there okay sure
and do you brush your teeth twice a day
we do you make sure to brush them before
you go to bed uh as far as my
girlfriend's concerned yes but on the
road not at all I'm like what am I going
I just ate all that pizza I hate it
cause I like it yeah
get rid of it yeah that's how
insensitive I respect it man I didn't
I'm telling a story in the show right
now I never did that but I did help a
neighbor pull his tooth
why where who
is I mean just back I just picture like
Castaway you got a figure skate this
right no but we had vice grip
dude what's wrong with you man that just
ruined my day dude your show's called
are you garbage I'm here saying yes why
are you getting squeamish guys dude vice
grips in a mouth you have a [__]
studio for this premise and you're upset
with my answers
was it a molar it was back there
it wasn't one of the front two I
couldn't doctor okay I couldn't get the
angle on it so I just kind of stood
around drinking while he gave it a shot
like he's grilling yeah
see if you can get in can You Yank It
you gotta twist the thing on the bottom
oh man holy [__] ladies and gentlemen
love it the Special shocks and struts on
YouTube right now absolutely fantastic
brother you the [__] man yeah thank
you anything you want the folks out
there to know hit him pulling away and
he dates or any insta whatever oh man
I'm just on tour forever so I'll be I'll
be somewhere that you live check him out
guys he's a [__] Stone Cold killer
one of the best one of the absolute best
to win it buddy congrats on the special
thank you so much for coming in congrats
on the studio thank you thank you
brother Kippy what do you got for him uh
we're also all over town we're getting
ready to announce the second leg of the
tour so it'll be the fall and winter got
to got the boys working on that but get
the tickets we have Cleveland Columbus
Louisville uh still left on this run get
those tickets before they're gone and
check out that are you garbage.com
that's where you can get your tickets
that's where you can pick up a couple of
teas gang we [__] love you to death
and we will see you next week peace